il ya quelques mois vous ai posé une
question j'ai fait une vidéo en vous
demandant qu'est ce que vous pensez qu
est ce que vous voudriez qui a ri pour
la chaîne les points à améliorer les
points négatifs et j'ai eu beaucoup de
retours mais désormais il faudrait
revoir un peu studio et beaucoup m'ont
dit franchement c'est le bordel je sais
hélas jusqu'à encore augmenter le level
au niveau du bordel j'ai carrément mis
cette fois ci une planète voilà une
palette à l'arrière que vous expliquez
dans quelques jours pourquoi j'ai une
palette
qu'est ce qui justifie mme palais c'est
le plus gros colis que j'ai reçus depuis
très très longtemps
81 kg à bout de bras on était deux quand
même cette saison
bon ça je vous en panne en quelques
jours aujourd'hui je vous parle de tout
autre chose je vous parle de monde
collecter je ne vous parle pas d'une
mode connecté je ne vous parle pas
pourquoi ce mot n'est fait correctement
de deux mondes connectés je vous parle
bien de trois mondes connectés qui nous
viennent tout droit de chine qui coûtent
moins de 100 euros chacune
je vais vous dire qu'en voile sombre
dans les voiles sont quand même plutôt
pas mal
[Musique]
j'en ai conscience rassurez-vous qu'il
faut améliorer le décor je ne savais pas
de souci alors je vous parle d'une
marque qui m'a contacté qui m'a dit
tiens monsieur gros on aimerait bien que
tu parles de nos montres on voudrait
proposer une vidéo sponso j'ai regardé
et j'ai dit ouais parce que déjà comme
je vous le dis bah il forcément rentrer
un peu d'argent pour payer la chaîne
permet de vivre et compagnie
en plus c'est pas mal parce que je vous
parle souvent de mondes connectés mais
je vous parle pas de monde connecté à
moins de 100 euros est là pour le coup
c'est le cas on est donc sur trois
mondes connectés une plutôt masculine
une plutôt féminine et une plutôt sport
comme ça on en a un peu pour tout le
monde
ce mode est plutôt masculin packaging
assez sympa c'est cette montre là alors
je vais vous la montrer en détail c'est
la w 30
les cotes sont pas hyper sexy il me le
monde font pas mal boyle une bonne dose
minutes je pense ça nous vient de chine
dont j'ai pas trop comment de prononcer
petite boîte qui est pas mal jamais tout
écolo et ça c'est sympa
vous avez une doc à l'intérieur qui vous
permet d'en savoir plus sans votre
montre alors attention si vous voulez
réussir à lire ça il faut absolument
parler anglais parce que vous avez soit
du chinois qui peut compliquer à parler
soit de l'anglais après vous allez
rageux vous montrer franchement c'est
pas très compliqué c'est pas sorcier
il ya une application sur smartphone
android et ios qui est par contre est
entièrement en français donc soyez
tranquilles rassurez vous si vous
parlais pas la langue de shakespeare
deux cas une fois vous en sortir la
deuxième c'est la montre pour le sport
pour la fitness c'est l'abbé 31 alors la
boîte est un peu moins un peu moins sexy
petit dock à l'intérieur alors c'est la
même chose soit en chinois soit en
anglais une fois de plus la pluie et en
français ça fonctionne
la montre est juste là dessous cachés à
l'intérieur la troisième boîte c'est
celle là c'est le modèle féminin
on le voit tout de suite on a vraiment
une touche davantage girly avec ce tir
haut ses modèles c'est l'abbé 36 bon
petit dock on restera la même chose
l'amour qui est là et maintenant je vous
parlais des montres en elle même la
première c'est celle là qui brassent lac
est facile à mettre un peu épaisses mais
pas trop vous avez trois types
d'affichage soit cet affichage là avec
le côté numérique lors la soie deuxième
affichage avec votre petite planète qui
tourne et votre cadrant avec vos
aiguilles soit un troisième affichage
avec la planète au milieu alors vous
avez plusieurs modes là dessus vous avez
déjà un mot sport mode sport pour aller
courir
voyez ça reconnais votre rythme
cardiaque la jeu
enlevez donc tout de suite il a un petit
peu de mal il cherche le rythme
cardiaque mais forcément il va pas le
trouver
normalement donc ça vous donne votre
rythme cardiaque ça vous dit depuis
combien de temps vous courrez le nombre
de pas que vous effectuez bon jusque là
géré que c'est un grand grand grand
classique et vous avez un deuxième mode
c'est un mode chronomètre vous démarrez
ici vous mettez la pause en bas vont
mettre à zéro là et là vous venez
choisir vous avez vos pas qui s'affiche
qui vous avez les calories que vous avez
brûlé oui la distance que vous avez
parcouru votre rythme cardiaque
le temps que vous avez dormi et là vous
pouvez venir activer votre appareil
photo à distance et vous voyez ici la
durée de batterie restante pour tous est
notifié de vos sms notifié d'un rappel
pouvait régler une horloge directement
depuis votre application
la recherche c'est hyper simple ça ses
demandes comme ça ici tout simplement de
l'autre côté vous avez l'usb vous
branchez vous avez une batterie de 135
millions terreur elles existent entre en
couleur ou en noir en blanc rouge et
après d'un point de vue technique elle
est certifié ip67 résistante à l'eau et
à la poussière c'est un écran ip est ce
que vous avez là ça y est vous pouvez
l'utiliser partir d'un os 10.3 ou
d'android 5.1
la deuxième manche n'a plus une montre
de sportifs c'est l'abbé 31
vous avez un petit bouton qui est juste
là on n'a plus cours vous venez naviguer
directement entre les différents menus
et un appui long vous rentrez dans le
menu alors le mur qu'elle pouvait entrer
c'est le menu sport c'est celui-là
voulait s'appuyer trois secondes vous
allez rentrer up dans le mode sport
vous allez avoir votre rythme cardiaque
vous allez avoir les calories dépensées
le nombre de pas la durée d'exercice que
vous avez pu ensuite vous étiez vous en
aviez vous pouvez soumettre la pause car
votre exercice soit venir sortir le
nombre de pages déjà effectué depuis ce
matin le nombre de kilomètres que j'ai
fait c'est pas fait grand chose
aujourd'hui le nombre de calories kcal
dépenser là c'est spo2 c'est
l'oxygénation de mons en fréquence de
mon rythme cardiaque voilà le nombre
d'offres demi et ensuite là je viens et
un de la montre un peu comme l'autre
modèle vous avez la notification des sms
des appels vous pouvez régler une alarme
toujours depuis une application et si
l'application s'appelle h bande donc la
vie à trois toutes les informations
venant de tout le montre leur le nombre
de pas mon activité bon sommeil j'ai pas
dormi avec votre rythme cardiaque
l'oxygénation du sang si et ça ça c'est
pour la deuxième montre vous montrerai
tout à l'heure ça dépend de votre sexe
vous avez toute votre activité avec le
nombre de pas par heure ce que vous avez
fait le nombre de kilos calories
dépensées pouvait calibre
rectif objectif de pas objectif de
sommeil vous révèle ensuite unités
métriques renvoyez pas mal de pas mal de
petites choses vous avez vos propres
paramètres avoue également si vous êtes
une femme un homme alors j'ai vu une
femme si vous montrez c'est pour la
lotte dallas prochaine monde que j'ai
réglé vous allez voir il ya un truc qui
est vachement intéressant et vous avez
toutes mes infos et des mallettes de
naissance ou une forêt cadeaux.fr pour
pour mon anniversaire
le seul défaut que je vais lui retrouvé
principalement axé son bracelet qui
n'est pas toujours évident à venir
accrocher au début vous avez ceux petits
picots qui doit venir se planter sur
votre bras ce lit d'hôpital vous l'avez
poser comme ça vous faites le tour là
vous devez venir ensuite vous mettre en
face appuyer suffisamment fort pour que
ça vienne transpercé de l'autre côté
éclat par contre sans position ça bouge
pas au début j'ai un petit peu galéré
après j'ai trouvé comment ça marche et
il faut quand même de bien faire sens
pas bien appuyé c'est un petit coup à
prendre celle là vous n'avez pas de
câble de recharge le câble est
directement dans le bracelet vouloir
charger directement sur le port usb et
après vous venez remettre ça comme ça ce
qui fait que vous vous en mettez pas
là-dessus il n'y a pas de charger c'est
une honte qu'il est certifié ip 68
résistante à l'eau et à la poussière au
même prendre votre douche avec tuera pas
de souci elle fonctionne avec du
bluetooth 4.0 vous avez une batterie de
140 millions perreur elle est dispo en
noir en bleu rouge wall d'année modèle
c'est celui que je préfère c'est l'abbé
36 or au delà d'un nom qui est un petit
peu codé pas forcément gg vous avez une
petite montre très féminine très
discrète et que je trouve assez élégante
vous avez un côté très classe avec ce
bracelet rouge n'y a pas que du rouillât
d'autres couleurs petit écran avec même
le fond noir quant à l'état ne trouve
vraiment très jolie vous avez siens
petits boutons sais pas si vous le
devinez que vous allez pouvoir naviguer
entre les différents modes vous avez là
le menu principal
la date ça c'est autre chose j'ai eu
arrive dans quelques instants si vous
expliquez vous retrouvez ensuite ici
bien votre mot sport voulait s'appuyer
trois secondes séparaient de la même
manière vous allez rentrer dans le mode
sport kaya le chronomètre qui commence à
se lancer vous avez toutes les infos
pour votre mode sport la pause en sortir
en sortir sans appui long de 3 secondes
ensuite je vais avoir le nombre de pas
que j'ai effectué aujourd'hui la
distance parcourue le nombre de kilos
calories que j'ai brûlé mon rythme
cardiaque
le nombre d'heures dormi et ici pour
être maman on est sur une monde qui est
destiné à un public féminin pourquoi
parce que vous avez une fonction qui est
très
sympa là-dessus qui vous sert à suivre
vos menstruations
vous allez pouvoir définir votre période
votre cycle mensuel est tout un suivi de
vos rêves et vous avez des petites
icônes qui nous permettront de tout
savoir sur votre période de règles donc
là vous êtes dans une période de règles
donc là c'est pour ça que ces petites
icônes qui apparut là vous avez une
période cypher la période cei c'est une
période dans lesquels vous êtes une
femme je peux rien vous apprendre sans
laquelle normalement vous n'avez
absolument aucun risque d'ovulation et
vous pouvez être avec votre conjoint
sans contraceptif fait quand même hyper
ya c'est que normalement tout se passe
mal 14e jour mais bon voilà voilà c'est
une indication donc ne prenez pas non
plus pour monnaie courante
vous avez la période d'ovulation vous
avez à la date d'ovulation et vous
retrouvez aussi sous forme de petites
couleurs donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
lorsque vous voulez avoir un suivi de
votre cycle menstruel
elle est bien évidemment disponible en
plusieurs couleurs rouge violet rose est
également noire elle est certifié ip 68
et prendre votre douche avec donc
certifié contre l'eau et la
transpiration
normalement ça devrait plutôt pas mal
s'est passé elle a une batterie de 100
millions paire eur elle est dispo à
partir d'android 2.4 ou alors de ios 8
vous avez aussi notification de sms
d'appel vous pouvez régler des alarmes
rien et pas mal de petites
fonctionnalités et elle va se recharger
avec ce petit câble là vous prenez vous
le positionner ces aimants t il était
tout seul deux côtés ça se recharge en
usb
l'abbé 31 c'est celle là c'est le mode
sport avec sa boîte qui vous coûtera 71
euros alors pas la boîte l'ensemble avec
la montre vous avez à côté de ça la b 36
le modèle féminin comme ça en rouge qui
est sympa coûte 69 euros et vous avez là
ew30 coûte 56 euros avec sa jolie boîte
en métal
on va donc on est sur des produits à
moins de 100 euros des produits qui sont
pas forcément trop cher qui s'adresse à
trois publics
femmes hommes que sportif vous pouvez
aussi l'utiliser pour faire du sport
courir avec vous êtes un relativement
tranquille alors je vous dis en termes
d'autonomie c'est démontre que vous
allez garder une journée voire plus si
affinités sont pas des écrans tactiles
attention ça il faut vraiment savoir là
sur le coup différents boutons sur le
côté là vous avez un bouton ou dessous
et là vous avez un bouton en dessous de
l'écran
si elle vous botte d'ailleurs je vous ai
mis des liens en dessous dans la
description vous pour aller les voir et
dites moi comment voulez trouver
est-ce que
montre connecter ce quelque chose qui
vous parle est-ce que vous en utilisez
déjà et est ce que vous pourriez acheter
ces modèles la voilà je voulais mais là
s'il vous botte une fois de plus vous
mets le lien en bas vous pouvez y aller
sans la description voilà pour ces
mondes connectés alors on en reparlera
vont pas d'une hotte monde connecté dans
quelques jours je vous invite donc à
vous abonner s'est pas déjà le cas
il vous donne rendez vous dès demain
j'embrasse ciao